As fans of Chicago Fire now know, Jesse Spencer
has left the building — Firehouse 51, that is. In
the fourth episode of the show's tenth season, his
character, Matthew Casey, goes to Oregon only to
find that Andy Darden's sons aren't doing
too well. After that, he has a heart-to-heart
conversation with Christopher Herrmann, in
which he basically says he is going to leave
Chicago to help take care of them. In a subsequent
episode, Casey deals with the fallout from that
decision — including his burgeoning romance with
Brett — before saying a final goodbye to the crew.
Spencer is one of the original Chicago Fire
cast members, having logged 200 episodes of
the show since it started airing in 2012. While
his character is supposedly going away for three
years, there are no guarantees that the actor
will be back at all. After such a long time on
the series, though, fans may be wondering
why the actor has decided to leave now.
With the cat out of the bag and his exit secured,
Spencer has explained his reasoning to the media.
In a recent video interview with Us Weekly,
Spencer said that he actually wanted to leave
the show between its ninth and tenth seasons,
but creator Derek Haas talked him into staying a
few more episodes so he'd have 200 of them on his
résumé. As it turned out, his reasons for leaving
the show were entirely personal. Notably,
Spencer has been in network television for
18 years straight, which is obviously a long
time whichever way you cut it. Spencer said:
"There's other things that I
would love to do in the future
and there's some family that
I need to take care of."
He added that he felt like his departure
storyline worked for him, saying:
"Casey's leaving and going to Oregon, therefore,
for the right reasons — it
all felt really organic."
But will Spencer return to the show
at some point? It's possible. In fact,
it sounds like talks have already begun to
bring him back to tie up some loose ends.
During the same interview, Haas was asked if
Spencer might come back for a special occasion,
and he gave an answer that should have
fans cautiously optimistic, saying:
"I'm hoping. I never try to predict
what's going to happen production-wise,
but we're in the camp of whenever Jesse
wants to come do an episode with us,
we will move mountains and
Earth to make that happen."
Spencer clarified that he plans to stay
in Chicago with his wife even though
he's stepping away from the show, which is a
little ironic — as the city's harsh climate
had him questioning whether to remain
on the series during its early years.
Obviously, 200 episodes on one TV show is
a monumental achievement for any actor,
and something few in the profession
will ever actually experience. It's also
something that Spencer himself thought might
not happen in the early days of Chicago Fire.
Cast members leave shows or get let go
for any number of reasons, ranging from
issues in their personal life to decisions
made by the writers. For Spencer, though,
it was the notoriously frigid Chicago winters that
had him unsure about his future on the series.
During an interview with Stage Right Secrets
about the 200th episode of Chicago Fire,
Spencer hailed the show's crew as
integral to the series' longevity.
While discussing the hard work the
crew regularly performed on the series,
he made special mention of Chicago's
cold temperatures. Spencer said:
"I mean, the weather. I didn't
think I'd last a year on the show.
After those winters, I was like,
'I don't know if I can do this.'"
Even though he plans to stay in Chicago
now that he has turned in his badge,
Spencer did indicate that he might
start booking vacations for himself
during the winter. During his
Us Weekly interview, he said:
"I still am in Chicago right now. I'm not
running off to Los Angeles [...] although I
might escape for a little bit of the winter. I
might snowbird, that's what I hear people do."
Wherever he goes, here's hoping he doesn't stray
too far from the Windy City
— or the set of Chicago Fire.
"I'm gonna miss it, I'm stepping
away, but I'll be back."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.